(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula, nós vamos estudar como proceder quando
um imóvel arrematado em leilão judicial está alugado.
Então, vamos lá.
O arrematante pode denunciar o contrato com prazo
de 90 dias para desocupação.
A gente já estudou aqui o que significa
denunciar um contrato.
Significa, efetivamente, o arrematante falar que ele não
quer seguir com aquele contrato de arrematação.
E aqui uma observação.
Você arrematou um imóvel alugado.
Você tem duas opções.
Uma é seguir com o contrato de locação.
Pode ser que você olhe aquele contrato e
fale olha, interessante, o imóvel está alugado por
um preço bom.
Eu quero seguir com esse contrato aqui porque
me interessa.
Pode ser que você olhe aquele contrato e
fale esse imóvel foi alugado por um preço
abaixo do mercado.
Ou eu quero vender esse imóvel.
Então, eu quero esse imóvel vazio para fazer
uma venda mais fácil.
Vai ficar a seu critério o que você
vai fazer.
Caso você escolha acabar com aquele contrato, você
deve fazer a denúncia do contrato de locação.
Você vai formalmente falar ao locatário que você
não quer mais aquele contrato.
A gente já estudou umas formas de fazer
isso, mas eu vou aqui recapitular.
Você pode fazer isso mandando um telegrama, que
aí você vai ter um comprovante de quando
ele recebeu aquele telegrama.
Você pode fazer isso por e-mail, um
aviso de recebimento.
Você pode fazer isso por uma carta com
um aviso de recebimento pelo correio, que aí
você também tem como comprovar quando foi que
aquela pessoa recebeu aquela carta.
Você pode fazer isso por uma mensagem no
WhatsApp, que vai ter lá a confirmação de
leitura.
Fica a seu critério, a forma como você
preferir, mas saiba que você deve comprovar quando
você fez a notificação para desocupação.
Então, você vai fazer a denúncia, vai notificar
aquele locatário que você não tem mais interesse
naquele contrato e você vai oferecer um prazo
de desocupação de 90 dias.
Então, você vai proporcionar 90 dias para que
aquela pessoa possa sair daquele imóvel.
Quando você deve realizar essa denúncia?
A denúncia deve acontecer dentro de 90 dias
a partir do registro do imóvel em nome
do arrematante.
Então, você, no leilão judicial, a gente falou
que existe a carta de arrematação e que
esse documento é o documento que você vai
levar ao cartório para que o cartório registre
o imóvel em seu nome.
Então, você foi lá, levou a carta de
arrematação no cartório e o cartório vai realizar
o registro em seu nome.
A partir da finalização do registro em seu
nome, você tem 90 dias para comunicar ao
locatário que você quer, por fim, aquele contrato
de locação.
Se você deixar passar esses 90 dias, você
vai concordar com a manutenção daquele contrato pelo
período que aquele contrato foi feito.
Então, dentro desses 90 dias, se você não
quiser, você deve realmente notificar o locatário, realizar
a denúncia do contrato e depois oferecer mais
90 dias para que aquela desocupação aconteça.
Isso sempre pode ser realizado?
Não.
Existe um caso muito específico em que a
denúncia não pode ser realizada que o arrematante
deverá cumprir aquele prazo de locação que foi
feito entre o antigo proprietário e o locatário.
Quais são esses casos?
Se o contrato de locação for por tempo
determinado, se o contrato tiver cláusula de vigência
em caso de alienação e se o contrato
estiver averbado na matrícula do imóvel.
Esses três requisitos aqui devem ser cumulativos.
Então, devem acontecer esses três requisitos para que
o arrematante tenha que esperar o fim desse
contrato de locação para pedir que o locatário
desocupe aquele imóvel.
É muito fácil para você, como arrematante, saber
se o contrato de locação cumpre esses requisitos
ou não.
Você não precisaria nem mesmo ter acesso a
esse contrato de locação, basta que você verifique
o terceiro requisito, que é o contrato que
está averbado na matrícula do imóvel.
A gente já falou inúmeras vezes aqui no
curso que a matrícula do imóvel, junto com
o edital do leilão, são os documentos mais
importantes para quem quer arrematar.
Você deve ler a matrícula do imóvel com
muita atenção.
Se você olhar a matrícula do imóvel, ler
atentamente, do começo ao fim, e não tiver
nada lá falando sobre um contrato de locação
que está em vigência, é porque aquele contrato
não está averbado na matrícula do imóvel.
Então, você pode ficar tranquilo que caso você
não queira manter aquele contrato de locação, você
vai realizar a denúncia do locatário e a
desocupação vai acontecer.
O que acontece na maioria dos casos de
contrato de locação?
Se for uma locação residencial, é muito difícil
você achar esse contrato averbado em matrícula.
Por quê?
Porque para averbar um contrato em matrícula, você
tem que pagar os custos do cartório de
registro de imóvel.
Então, as pessoas escolhem não fazer isso com
o contrato de locação residencial.
É raríssimo você encontrar um contrato de locação
residencial averbado na matrícula do imóvel.
É mais comum encontrar essa averbação num contrato
de locação de um imóvel comercial.
Porque o contrato de locação de um imóvel
comercial, dependendo do imóvel, ele já tem um
valor bem mais elevado.
Então, é mais comum que as pessoas só
façam essa averbação de uma locação comercial, não
faça de uma locação residencial.
Você, como arrematante, vai conseguir facilmente essa informação,
é só você olhar para a matrícula.
Se a matrícula não tiver essa informação de
que existe um contrato de locação, você pode
arrematar sem medo e depois realizar a denúncia.
Quando o arrematante arremata esse imóvel, esse imóvel
está alugado, ele tem direito a receber os
valores desse contrato de locação.
A partir de quando o arrematante tem direito
a receber esses valores?
O arrematante pode entrar em contato com o
locatário e pedir que esses valores sejam pagos
diretamente para ele a partir do auto de
arrematação.
Aqui, nesse caso, você não precisa esperar o
registro do imóvel em seu nome.
Basta que você tenha o auto de arrematação,
você já pode pedir que o locatário pague
o aluguel mensalmente em sua conta, você vai
lá disponibilizar a conta.
O que é auto de arrematação?
A gente vai explicar melhor numa aula de
procedimento pós-leilão que a gente tem aqui
um pouco mais para frente nesse módulo.
Mas eu já vou deixar a informação que
quando um leilão acaba com lance, quando tem
um vencedor para aquele leilão, o leiloeiro faz
o auto de arrematação.
Nesse auto de arrematação, o leiloeiro vai comunicar
quem eram as partes que estavam envolvidas naquele
leilão, quem é o arrematante daquele leilão, qual
o valor do arrematante, se o pagamento vai
ser parcelado, se vai ser à vista.
E esse é o documento que o leiloeiro
faz no caso do leilão judicial para comunicar
ao juiz que ocorreu arrematação para aquele imóvel.
Então, o leiloeiro faz esse auto de arrematação
imediatamente.
Geralmente, dentro de 24 horas depois do leilão,
esse auto de arrematação já está pronto.
Então, basta que você, como arrematante, tenha esse
auto de arrematação que você já pode pedir
que você receba esse valor de aluguel mensal,
mesmo se você for pedir a denúncia.
A gente falou que a denúncia você vai
ter que conceder a um prazo de 90
dias para que a pessoa possa desocupar aquele
imóvel.
Nesse prazo de 90 dias, você recebe aquele
aluguel normalmente, você não vai deixar de receber.
Então, você também já pode disponibilizar a sua
conta, mesmo que você faça a opção por
denunciar aquele contrato.